today the night will show a new survey
reveals that all of the fundamental
values that once defined our
civilization and every other
civilization are dying away in this
country but this is not an accident and
has been the left's agenda all along
we'll talk about that also trans
Insurrection has stormed the Kentucky
State Capitol waging an assault on our
democracy and our very way of life a
Democrat lawmaker screams hysterically
at a republican over gun control somehow
the Democrat thinks he comes off the
best in the exchange the NHL may be
pulling back from its gay pride agenda
after a small handful of players refused
to go along with it an important lesson
there for for all of us and speaking of
important lessons in our daily
cancellation I'll finally deliver the
definitive and unquestioned list of
rules for air travel very important all
of that and more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
if it's time to start making big changes
in your life there's no better place to
start than to take control of your
credit card debt you need to check out
light stream credit card consolidation
from lightstream can help you pay off
your credit cards and lock in a low
fixed interest rate start is 7.99 APR
with auto pay an excellent credit plus
the rate is fixed so it will never
increase over the life of your loan you
can get a loan from five thousand to 100
uh to a hundred thousand dollars without
any fees you can even get your money as
soon as the day you apply lightstream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience that's
exactly what they deliver just for my
listeners you can apply now to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to lightstream.com
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com subject credit
approval rates range from 7.99 APR to
23.99 APR and include 0.5 auto pay
discount lowest rate requires excellent
credit terms and conditions apply and
offers are subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.com Walsh for
more information
I had originally planned to begin this
week with a topic that had to be pushed
off after the trans terrorist shooting
at the Christian School here in
Nashville but now in light of the events
of this week it takes on I think an even
more uh even more urgency so on Monday
morning the Wall Street Journal
published poll results which uh throw
into Stark relief a certain cultural
reality that has been clear to some of
us for a long time but not nearly clear
enough to most of us the publication
reports quote patriotism religious Faith
having children and other priorities
that helped Define the national
character for Generations are receding
in importance to Americans a new Wall
Street Journal norc poll finds the
survey conducted with norc at the
University of Chicago a nonpartisan
research organization also finds the
country sharply divided by political
party over social trends such as the
push for racial diversity in businesses
and the use of gender-neutral pronouns
some 38 of respondents said patriotism
was very important to them and 39 said
religion was very important that was
down sharply from when the journal asked
the question of the first time in 1998
when 70 percent deemed part uh
patriotism to be very important and 62
percent said so of religion the sheriff
Americans who say that having children
involvement in their community and hard
work are very important has also Fallen
tolerance for others deemed very
important by 80 of Americans as recently
as four years ago has fallen to 58 since
then the only priority the journal
tested that has grown in importance in
the past quarter century is money which
was cited as very important by 43
percent in the new survey which was up
from 31 in 1998.
now by the way the fact that people
value money is of course not in itself a
bad thing I mean I value money I value
money a lot because it's how I provide
for my family so it is very important
but the problem is that while people
value money more than they did in the
past they don't value hard work nearly
as much and they don't value having
children so this tells us that many
Americans want money for their own sake
to buy things for themselves but they
don't want to work for it
so it's like the worst of all worlds
great you know it's it's one thing to be
hard-working and greedy
it's not good to be greedy but if you're
hard-working and greedy you can even
achieve great things motivated that way
um but to be but to be greedy and lazy
at the same time is the again the worst
of all worlds
as expected um the Gap in values can be
seen not just across decades but also by
comparing Generations The Wall Street
Journal again reports quote aside from
money all age groups including seniors
attached far less importance to these
priorities and values than when
pollsters asked about them in 1998 and
in 2019 but younger Americans in
particular place a low importance on
these values many of which were Central
to the lives of their parents some 23 of
adults under age 30 said in the new
survey that patriotism was very
important to them personally compared
with 59 percent of seniors ages 65 or
older
some 31 percent of younger respondents
said that religion was very important to
them compared with 55 among seniors only
23 of adults under age 30 said that
having children was very important
um and there's a lot more to the results
but those I think are the highlights or
low lights depending on how you look at
it now I normally don't lend a lot of
credibility or weight to polls and
surveys but these results simply
quantify help us to visualize something
that was already well apparent to
anybody who was remotely paying
attention
we are
um a culture that has increasingly
abandoned all of the values and
priorities and principles that defined
not only past generations of Americans
but all generations of all people who
have ever lived anywhere on the planet
these are for the most part Universal or
what used to be Universal human values
that are now fading away dying out in
this country
and and here's what we need to
understand about all this
first and foremost this this is the
agenda okay these results have been
engineered it's not the product of
happenstance or uh you know the
inevitable conclusion of the passage of
time as Camilla Harris would say
human civilization existed for thousands
of years and for thousands of years all
cultures everywhere though separated by
time and location
still all valued family
procreation religion patriotism hard
work achievement
these values manifested themselves in
different ways obviously took on
different forms but nearly everyone
would have agreed on the most basic
fundamentals here
you could have
uh you know pick almost any time in the
past in the year 1803 or or 1555 or you
know 300 BC you could have pulled anyone
anywhere even people removed from each
other by oceans or generations and they
would have said yes of course I value
family yes of course I want to have
children and continue my bloodline and
you know pass down wealth and prosperity
to my progeny yes of course I love my
country my community My Tribe yes of
course I worship my God or my gods yes
of course I believe that I should work
and you know do some kind of work and
provide for myself and my family
these are the answers you would have
heard anywhere
it is only now here in this culture at
this time that people will tell you they
fundamentally don't care about any of
that
the last agenda has been precisely this
to eat away at these core essential
human values to destroy the very things
that have have defined individuals and
Nations for millennia
the these are the things that that make
a person a person and a People a people
and this is also what the culture war is
all about
okay it's about on our side defending
these basic values when we call
ourselves conservatives this is
what we're trying to conserve so when
you hear someone scoff at the culture
War
this is what they're scoffing
they're scoffing at the notion that we
should even bother defending the core
human values that bind a civilization
together and ensure its continued
flourishing
when someone dismisses the culture war
and says it's uh you know it's silly
it's unimportant
tired of all these culture War issues
well they are dismissing as unimportant
and as silly the priorities and beliefs
that are rooted deepest in the human
soul
who cares about it what priorities and
beliefs rooted deepest the human soul
what does that matter
and what happens when those roots are
torn out
is a a new tree planted in its place no
there's nothing else to plant
so all that's left is a whole
and that's all they intend to leave
this is the way it always works
they tear out the thing and they tear it
out by the roots and they PLA and they
put nothing you just have a hole there
in the ground
they want to take away everything
everything you love and value and
replace it with emptiness
that's why the decline in these values
has not been answered with an increase
in new values now sure people might say
they value diversity and inclusion and
Equity or whatever but first of all it
doesn't take much digging to see that
They Don't Really value any of of that
but second those aren't real values
anyway those are slogans those are
things that you you people put on
posters uh those are those are those are
values for HR seminars okay that's what
those values are they are not values for
Nations
they aren't values for Civilizations for
human beings
in the past people who valued family and
children and God religion Faith country
hard work sacrifice they were driven by
those values to achieve extraordinary
things
okay to achieve like everything that we
benefit
from today
uh all the things that we have and the
luxuries we take for granted and the
rights we take for granted all of that
was given to us by people who value all
of the things that we are now discarding
these are the people who discovered new
lands and who built Nations out of
wilderness and invented things and built
things made made beautiful art and
sailed across seas and figured out how
to fly and how to go into space
it requires skill and intelligence to do
those things both of which are also in
short supply these days but but but you
also won't even attempt to do them
unless you value something Beyond
yourself
a man must know how to do something
great
but he must first be motivated to even
bother trying
we used to produce people like that
the people who built the civilization
that we're now destroying
because we instilled in them from birth
the values that would drive and sustain
them in their pursuit of something great
so what I'm saying is that
when we talk about valuing family
and procreation children God Work
country Faith sacrifice
these are not just the best values for
forming and maintaining a civilization
they are the only ones
that's it
they're the only game in town there are
no alternatives
if you do not value those things
then you are left with nothing you are
left as a person who values nothing
and you are left with a culture that
values nothing
you either value those or you value
nothing there are no other options
now there were some there are some who
would say well if you don't value those
things you know instead you value
yourself it's it's like a selfish thing
but even that's not exactly true because
if you value yourself the way you ought
to Value yourself
you would care about family country
children Etc
you know if you value yourself you're
not gonna you're not gonna embrace your
own Extinction the extinction of your
bloodline
and say I don't I don't need to have
children I don't need I don't need any
purpose in life I don't need to you know
I'll die alone and be forgotten and I'm
okay with that
if you value yourself you wouldn't be
you wouldn't be okay with that
so no instead our culture um cultivates
a population
which values
you know with with people and
individuals who value not even really
themselves per se but more specifically
their own comfort and the satisfaction
of their own immediate desires Above All
Else
in dostoevsky's words they they value
the multiplication and Rapid
satisfaction of Desire
that's what the whole culture is about
now that's it
okay you ask someone to ask somebody the
meaning of life
and if they're even articulate enough to
explain it that's what that's what it is
to them
the rapid satisfaction and
multiplication of Desire this is what we
have replaced the old values with
a man isn't driven to love his country
and his God to work hard for his family
and for his children rather he's called
by the culture to focus on to Champion
to celebrate and to satisfy his desires
the more desires the better the more
depraved and degenerate the better
these are the new values of the new man
and it's what we're fighting against
now let's get to our five headlines
you know living a healthy lifestyle can
be challenging when you're always on the
go you need a simple manageable routines
to make sure that you're getting the
proper nutrition every day which is why
I'm a huge fan of balance of nature
balance of nature fruits and veggies are
a great way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day their capsules are packed
with 100 whole food that you can take at
any time bouts of nature use a cold
vacuum process that preserves the
natural antioxidants and 16 whole fruits
and 15 whole vegetables and encapsulates
them for easy consumption they sent a
bunch of fruits and veggie capsules down
to the studio for my team to try the
whole team is feeling brighter healthier
more energetic when you're disciplined
enough to take care of your health you
reap all kinds of benefits make fruits
and vegetables a part of your daily diet
your body will thank you right now
balance of nature is offering 35 off
with your first preferred order so go to
bouncenature.com use promo code walls
for 35 off that's balance of nature Dot
com promo code Walsh
a lot to cover here we'll start with a
report in the AP
Associated Press which is uh the the
bias in the reporting here will be very
obvious to you uh but I'll read it as
it's written Republican lawmakers in
Kentucky on Wednesday swept aside the
Democratic Governor's veto of a bill
regulating some of the most personal
aspects of life for transgender young
people from Banning access to gender
farming Healthcare to restricting the
bathrooms they can use the votes to
override Governor Andy beshears veto
were lopsided in both legislative
Chambers where the GOP wield super
majorities and came on uh the next to
last day of this year's legislative
session the Senate voted 29-8 to
override bashir's veto a short-term way
to the house completed the override on
the veto 76-23 as a motion surged some
people protesting the bill from the
house Gallery were removed and arrested
after their prolonged chanting ring out
in the chamber the protesters their
hands bound chanted there's more of us
not here as they waited to be taken away
from the capitol so uh that's the the
language of a media bias but in in plain
English language what actually happened
is the uh Republicans and state
legislature tried to pass a bill that uh
should be very similar to bills that
have been passed in Tennessee in other
states uh Banning the mutilation and
castration sterilization of children and
also stipulating uh other Common Sense
things like if you're a boy used the
boys room your girl use a girl's room
um those sorts of things the Democratic
governor vetoed it he said no absolutely
not uh he said you know we we want to
continue sterilizing and castrating and
butchering children that's something
that uh that we care deeply about says
the governor and you know in so many
words and then the Republicans vetoed uh
you know over over uh overrode his veto
and then
these protesters that we hear about are
actually according to the left's own
language
um according to their standards again
these are insurrectionists in left-wing
trans insurrectionists violent
left-wing trans
insurrectionists who hate democracy uh
waged in attack on Democracy itself they
attacked the very foundations of this
country by invading the capital and we
have just uh there's a lot of videos of
a lot of footage of the scenes that were
carried out from there but here's Just
One Quick Clip Shake
so can we see this guy here the guy with
the horns yeah right there
so a couple things about this first of
all they were apparently they were
eventually escorted out by police
um but the uh one thing we know is that
so here we have here we have I guess the
trans the the non-binary uh demon Shaman
um this guy ain't going to prison for
three years like the Q Anon Shaman with
the Buffalo horns okay he went to prison
for what was it three years that's not
happened to this guy that's not happened
to any of these people even though Again
by their standards that's what this is
this is an Insurrection this is invading
the capital bill you have no right to be
there in staging this uh this protest
and um
but they're not gonna be going to prison
for that maybe they were escorted out by
police eventually but they're not going
to be going to prison for it the other
thing too that I you know I appreciate I
guess he's dressed up
so he's got this kind of like Priestly
garb
clown makeup devil horns
when you see these videos of these trans
activist extremists
one thing is when you watch somebody you
can you can really almost and I'm
sitting so close to the screen I can
smell this video that's the thing when
you see these people you can smell them
through the screen and that's kind of
disturbing but what I what I appreciate
about it is that they make it so easy
to oppose them okay they they always
make it so
apparent and so clear who the bad guys
are because they'll literally dress as
demons in case there's any any uh
confusion if you ever become confused
about it and there shouldn't be because
they are they are protesting in favor of
castrating sterilizing children so
that's all you should need to know but
if you ever become a little bit confused
and you see you know chaos and you're
looking at these clips and you're
thinking who's the good guy who's
backing well the people dressed as
demons they're the bad guys okay so they
they are making that very clear to you
and you can't appreciate that much at
least
speaking of uh demons in the capital we
go to DC representative Jamal Bowman a
Democrat decided to start screaming like
a hysterical woman at representative
Thomas Massey who's a Republican and uh
not only just any Republican by the way
is Thomas Massey he's uh one of the good
ones you know there's not a lot but he's
uh one of the best Republicans in DC by
Far and Away
and he got into well this is being
this being described by people on social
media and some of the media as a as a
shouting match between Thomas Massey and
Jamal Bowen it is not a shouting match
this is a one-sided match because only
one person is shouting and that is Jamal
Bowman he posted the clip that we're
about to play he posted on his own
Twitter page he's very proud of himself
he thinks that he comes off looking very
good here
because he was saying things loudly
and we all know that whoever's saying it
the loudest is automatically right
so we judge rightness by volume at least
that's what they do on the left
and uh let's watch the video
I'm talking about gun violence balance
Terry guys you think
two times
more guns lead to more death look at the
data you're not looking at any data
you're you're carrying the water for the
gun lobby no no look at the data more
does need the more deaths good states
that have open carry laws have more debt
in every school banks that have open
carry the laws have more deaths are you
listening to what I'm saying calm down
children are dying
nine-year-old children the solution is
that arm and teachers have you ever
worked in a school have you ever worked
in the school have you ever worked in
the school
have you ever worked in a school it's a
yes or no question have you ever worked
at the school you will not answer my
question don't stop and talk okay I'll
bring it down a notch have you ever
worked in the schools
for 20 years
[Music]
and protected everything
he can't even answer yes or no question
ask them why would they pass legislation
what answer the question ask him right
now make him answer
I really appreciate this video I'm glad
that he posted it
um because it really encapsulates just
in less than two minutes there
uh it really encapsulates the gun debate
in this country because you have one
side
screaming hysterically
um with nothing to say okay all they
have are slogans
that's all they have
and also irrelevant you know he spends
30 seconds there trying to it's a yes or
no question have you have you ever
worked in a school have you worked in a
school have you yes or no question
what the hell does that have to do with
anything you think is that's the
ultimate gotcha why won't you answer the
question of whether you worked in school
no I didn't so
have you ever been a plumber like what
what does that have to do with anything
um all he has are these slogans
and slogans
um ad hominem shouting
and uh you know red herrings irrelevant
irrelevant misnomers like that's that's
it and you saw it all there in the video
so if we were to walk through some of
these
first of all he says more guns lead to
more death and he keeps repeating it
over while Thomas Massey is trying to
okay calm down calm down you child let's
have a conversation like adults more
guns more deaths literally a child okay
this is the way a child thinks more guns
more death
you are you are a child
and the exact context here is that
Thomas Massey said well if teachers
okay if he had teachers who were trained
and armed
then they're not going to be defenseless
he says well that's more death
walk me through that Jamal how does that
work exactly
okay so what you're saying what you're
saying is that uh when a when a bad guy
with a gun walks into a school building
it is better
if the good guys don't if they are
disarmed it's better
so the bad guy with the gun walks into
the school building shoots her way in
this case bad woman with a gun shoots
her way into the building
um
you would not be in favor of any of the
teachers there having guns because you
think that if they had guns there'd be
more death how does that work but what
the the the the
psychopath Mass shooter walks in and
then you've got some teachers that have
guns and it leads to more debt why
because what they just randomly start
shooting their own students what are you
even saying okay this the trans
terrorist
goes up to the second floor
starts spraying bullets kills three
staff members and three children
let's take those staff members for a
moment
they were unarmed okay uh and
defenseless
are you saying Jamal that it's actually
better that they were unarmed in that
situation
the psychopath is there
teachers are there the moment before the
guns the the you know the bullets start
flying
can we improve the situation and improve
the odds of the victims by giving them
guns or no what you're saying is no it
is better for them to be defenseless
this is a psychotic point of view it's
not just factually Incorrect and
illogical it is psychotic you are saying
that it is better in a situation if you
are defenseless
now you might respond and say well the
better thing is if the bad person isn't
there at all doesn't have a gun either
yeah of course that's better of course
it's better if they're not there of
course it's better if the shooting isn't
happening in the first place of course
it's better of course we would all
prefer if uh if if the mass shooter
doesn't show up in the first place but
they do show up and when you're in a
situation where they are there it's
better if they weren't you wish they
weren't but they are so what do we do
now
how do you mitigate the damage that is
about to happen
is it better for the victims to remain
defenseless where all they could do is
huddle in a corner or fling themselves
defenseless at the the psychopath with a
gun
or would we like to give them a chance
he says no don't give him a chance
what he's saying is
psychopath of the gums comes into the
school
your obligation is to Simply die to
Simply die until the police show up
and if the police show up and if they're
courageous and skilled and everything
like the National Police Department then
uh then you know six people will die
in the meantime
if the police are incompetent and scared
then many more will die people will die
for over an hour like in Uvalde but what
Jamal Bowman is saying is that that's
that's your responsibility that's the
responsibility of the parents of the of
the teachers the staff members and the
students is to Simply die because he
doesn't want them to have the ability to
defend themselves
he says 40 45 45 States all right no he
doesn't say four sorry he says he says
it stays with open carry have more
deaths
well I've already spoiled the ending
here but do you know how many you might
have you know how many you know how many
states have open carry laws 45 out of
50. okay nearly every state nearly the
entire country has open carry laws
so when he says that the states with
open carry laws have more deaths he's
saying that that applies to almost
everybody so it's it's a meaningless
statistic it doesn't mean anything
and what he
just wants to skip over entirely
is that
the vast majority of homicides in this
country
okay the vast majority are not happening
at the hands of uh concealed carry
permit holders or even people who are
open carrying you know uh right wing Red
State
gun uh Second Amendment Advocates open
carrying because it like that's those
these are not the people
who are carrying out the vast majority
of homicides in this country
they are happening in cities
at the hands of thugs and criminals
uh and in these cities with strict gun
laws already
vast majority of cases they're happening
at the hands of people who don't have
the legal right to carry those guns in
the first place they've got criminal
records already they're you know all of
that that's what they're happening
but he doesn't want to talk about that
either of course doesn't want to talk
about anything he just wants to scream
you know it's a scream and then brag
about it
absolute clown
um
here's some good news
in the wake of uh this is from daily
wire in the wake of several NHL players
refusing to wear a pride themed attire
the league is reportedly considering
shelving Pride night events at its games
last week two brothers who are teammates
on the NHL's Florida Panthers refused to
wear a pride themed sweater during the
team's warm-up skate citing their
religious beliefs
um Eric and Mark Stahl joined San Jose
Sharks goalie uh James Reimer and
Philadelphia Flyers defenseman Yvonne
rivarov who had also refused to take
warm-ups take part in warm-ups with
pride themed jerseys
this is very good news
um and it's it's uh
a lesson for once a good lesson you know
a positive lesson for the rest of us
so the NHL
went Uber woke uh and they started doing
these ridiculous Pride night things and
they're just vomiting rainbow colors all
over the place and vomiting it all over
the fans and and everything
most of the NHL players
were obedient little cowards and went
along with it
it took how many people
um four
four NHL players four of them took a
stand and said it wasn't big dramatic or
anything like that they weren't overly
confrontational about it they weren't
confrontational at all all they said is
no I'm not gonna
taking a stand here was simply saying no
it took four people four people to say
no I'm not doing this
and already the NHL might be abandoning
the whole thing
and what that tells us is that it
doesn't take much it just me you have to
speak up and you have to say no
and if even you know one person has to
go first if one person does it the next
person feels more safe to do it and then
the next person the next person you have
the domino effect and uh oftentimes it
doesn't take much before results happen
and and you know when we when we look
around the culture and everything and we
see so often uh it seems like we're not
getting results and it feels very
deflating and hopeless
well in many cases we're not getting the
results because we're not even trying
once you try you start to see the
results we're seeing this not just in
the NHL with pride night I mean going
back to the gender issue we're seeing
real you know it's it felt like this
um
Unstoppable March of gender craziness
and gender Madness the Transcendent
ideology on the March for several
several years it felt like it's it's not
there's no stopping it
but then there was a concerted effort to
actually oppose it
and it wasn't like it was even millions
of people all organized against it it's
really only a comparative few
but in response to that we're already
seeing results
so it doesn't take much but you gotta
you know you got to stand up and say no
so lots of uh credit goes to those NHL
players more good news
and an update on a story we talked about
yesterday this is from the daily wire
Jocelyn Berry press secretary for
Democratic Arizona governor Katie Hobbs
has resigned after posting an
inflammatory tweet suggesting quote
transphobes should be gunned down in the
wake of a woman who identified as
transgender killing six people at a
Christian School Nashville
we talked about this yesterday this is
Jocelyn Berry the uh the spokeswoman for
Katie Hobbs posted this this meme you
know uh this is what we do with
transphobes and it's a it's an image of
a woman holding a gun
posted that you know not not five
seconds after the shooting when maybe
she didn't hear about it hours after the
shooting on the same day she definitely
knew about it she posted that anyway
um and we talked about on the show
yesterday and it was it was up for
almost an entire day wasn't even deleted
finally the the the uh the backlash
started to gain some momentum and she
shut down her account
um and then finally several hours later
after many calls from people on the
right saying you got to fire this woman
this is unacceptable
and they were calls by the way almost
entirely from the right there are fewer
a few exceptions and some notable ones I
saw actually uh Keith olberman
was maybe the one guy on the left and I
was off to say credit where it's due
there's a one time my life I'll give any
credit all to Keith Olbermann but Keith
olberman tweeted something uh saying
that this is unacceptable and it's not
appropriate she should be fired
now he did follow that up by admitting
that his main concern is that do it you
know when when when uh Democrats do this
kind of thing it only gives ammunition
to the right so that's what he's
concerned about but still
he said that she should resign uh but it
was mostly you know 99.9 people on the
right calling for this
um and then the governor did cave put
out a statement saying the governor does
not condone violence in any form this
Administration holds respect at the
Forefront mutual respect to the
Forefront of uh of how we engage with
one another sure the post by the press
secretary is not reflective of the
values of the administration the
governor has received and accepted the
resignation of the press secretary
resignation quote unquote
um
what that means is that we successfully
got her fired
which is a very good thing she deserved
to be fired
um
and this was us holding them to their
own standard
that I don't care you know the other
side can say oh well now you're engaging
in cancel culture this is canceled sure
whatever call it what you want I really
don't care call it what you want
but you have set up the rules
okay
and uh and now we're going to force you
to play by them
and you could whine and complain all you
want it doesn't matter
uh very glad that this woman lost her
job in her livelihood I could not be
happier
and I hope that she is unable to get any
other job that's what I hope
all right
I want to play this way this is one of
the
saddest videos that
I've seen uh in in some time or I'll say
one of the most pathetic videos that
I've seen in some time Richard Dawkins
was interviewed by Piers Morgan
and this doesn't need a lot of setup but
he was a subject was broached with
Richard Dawkins that Piers Morgan
thought he didn't mean if you could tell
he didn't mean this to be a gotcha I
didn't mean he didn't think it'd be like
a difficult question but Richard Dawkins
was
terrified to talk about it
and uh was not hiding his fear at all
let's watch this big debate about this
Isis bride shamima begum whether she
should be allowed to come back to this
country do you have a view about that
I'm not saying
you're over and I'll say I haven't
started it enough well she was married
to an Isis fighter yeah I know she was a
young but she was 15 when she went out
there yeah the debate really is what she
groomed to be part of this terror group
in Syria and as such should we show
mercy and allow her back to this country
yes I'm not going to say about that are
you worried about me do you get threats
because of the positions you've taken on
some of these things
when you saw what happened to Salman
rush to you
didn't send a shot of three
are you saying no you don't want to talk
about it or yes right I mean that's
interesting in itself because is it
there are areas which you would prefer
not to discuss
I should have said that before we
started yeah no medicine I I'm
I think it's sad that you can't
I don't think anything should be off
limits in interviews with people like
you the whole point of the world's
smartest thinkers is we ought to better
have free and open debate but I don't
think we do because people use murderous
retribution against free speech
wow that's that is actually brutal
that's that's tough to watch uh and I'm
not someone maybe wouldn't surprise
you'll learn I'm not someone with uh
terrible amount of respect for for
Richard Dawkins but this is actually why
you know it's not obviously outspoken
atheist and all that uh so I'm going to
disagree with him on on those grounds
but
this is actually why I've never had a
whole lot of respect for him because I
just haven't bought you know he has this
reputation or had anyway in the past
certainly not anymore of being a
Fearless independent thinker who's going
to say what he thinks and all that and I
never bought it and here you see
just like
too afraid to even speak words about it
he won't say anything he's he's sitting
there I don't think I've seen I've seen
people Dodge questions before because
they're afraid of the backlash if they
say what they really think so we're
quite used to seeing that in interviews
that's like almost every interview on
cable news is is that but um
he won't say anything he's sitting there
shaking his head stop stop
um
because he's uh he's terrified and it's
especially pathetic in his case because
you're how old is Richard Dawkins he's
in his 80s you know he's in his he's in
his 80s and uh
made a lot of money what what are you
afraid of exactly
you should you should very much be in
the phase of your life where you don't
care what anyone thinks and you're just
gonna say exactly what you think all the
time now I think that's how we should
all operate always but uh you've got no
excuse when you're wealthy and old
to not have that attitude
so yet another Fearless uh independent
intellectual exposes himself as anything
but that let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
are you ready to take the next step in
your education but feeling overwhelmed
by uh everything that you have going on
and everything that's on your plate well
Grand Canyon University's online
programs are designed to make earning
your degree easy and accessible no
matter your age or your stage in life
whether you're a busy professional
looking to advance your career or a
stay-at-home parent juggling family
responsibilities whatever you got going
on their online courses give you the
flexibility you need to learn on your
own terms which is the way that it ought
to be Grand Canyon University
specializes in helping you fit your
bachelor's Master's or doctoral degree
into your busy schedule from
scholarships to customized scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with personal
support and everything else that you
need to succeed so why wait if you're
ready to take your education to the next
level you need Grand Canyon University
find your purpose at Grand Canyon
University visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
two sides one stone says no there's zero
reason to give any Spotlight to any
Manifesto of a monster in fact one of
the last uh shootings Ben Shapiro said
focusing on
the manifesto creates copycats now even
he is talking about this Manifesto like
he's lost his values yet again the focus
is on the shooter no one can recite the
victim's names they don't know about
their lives they don't know about their
families they don't even know what class
they were taking when they were gunned
down but we know about the shooter's
childhood even her family her parents
marriage dating back 30 years to Candace
harping thanks to Candace harping on
this criminal make the shooter disappear
we all know why she attacked a school
and it will uh happen again if DW
doesn't enforce its do not name rule
with all the toasts other Shooters will
Marvel at the sick person Spotlight and
more shootings will happen focus on the
victims security in schools Christian
culture and killing this uh trans
movement that brainwash radicalized and
destroyed a woman turning her into a
devil okay
uh
Fair points
but I'll a couple of points I'll say in
response first of all you're making an
argument that
just to be clear about what the argument
is
uh
then I'm gonna assume this is your
argument
that the media shouldn't publicize
anything in the manifesto or talk about
the Killer
and I'll address that in a moment
but that is not an argument for the
government to withhold this information
from the public
so we talk about releasing the manifesto
uh I would hope you would agree that
even though you don't think the media
should harp on it it should still be
released because the public has a right
to know
a community that was attacked in this
way has a right to know who did it and
why they did it
doesn't change anything for those who
are mourning it obviously doesn't give
them back what they have lost but we
have a right to know and more
importantly the government has no right
to not tell us okay the government has
no right to be the only ones who know
now as for the media you may have
noticed that that I have never really
abided by the daily wires policy on not
naming Shooters I've often named them in
the past so this is not new for me I'm
on the commentary side not the news side
so it's been uh it's been left up to my
discretion you know it's not there are
journalistic standards and rules and
everything that apply in any
organization to uh news reporters that
don't apply to you if you're commentary
this is I'm giving my perspective I'm
not pretending to uh be giving like a
you know just an objective recitation of
the facts the whole point is for me to
tell my perspective
so it's different different uh kind of
Standards apply
but even as the policy goes
look not all situations are the same
and you can have a policy that that uh
that applies most of the time but when
you have this kind of uh this is why you
know so-called Zero Tolerance policies
in general in almost any context are
foolish I mean they're foolhardy because
you have to allow for
the application of discernment and for
the recognition that sometimes
situations arise that are that are
different from the other sorts of
situations you deal with you have to be
willing to acknowledge that and
recognize that and respond to it
and sometimes other factors become
overriding factors
so here in this case
there is a truth
a very important truth
that I have known and some of us have
known and that I have warned about
but that much of the public does not
know and should know
and that is the truth that this movement
this trans ideology movement is
radicalized violent extreme
this is a real thing it is a real
problem and they don't want you to know
about it
the powers that be don't want you to
know about it
it has to be made known
um
and that is the point of of releasing
the manifesto that's what makes it
especially important in this case
because there are certain cultural
realities that people actually don't
understand and they need to it literally
lives are at stake
so the radicalizing as much as we hear
about radicalization from the media
here's a place where it actually applies
the radicalizing rhetoric of the trans
ideology movement
is uh is is a is a is a a real crisis
people need to know that
and this is something that would uh I
think make that very clear
so all the concerns that you mentioned
are valid
but I think the value of the plain
unvarnished truth in this case
is uh
takes precedent
over over the concerns that you've
mentioned
um
Tado says Matt seems to be getting
harsher and harsher with each episode
since P since people blamed him for
being too mean to Dylan Mulvaney and I
must say I absolutely love it this harsh
course is the only course which will
actually accomplish our goals am I being
more harsh really I've always been I
don't think I've changed much in that
regard but maybe I have uh Dave says the
manifesto from the mass shooter in New
Zealand was released the next day well
of course it is that's that's why you
know if as we've been talking about if
it's uh
you know if it's someone that the media
will try to claim is right wing or
whatever white supremacist
um then we're going to see that
Manifesto right away which is yet
another reason why it should be released
this also this also goes back to holding
to the same standard you know we want
same standard applied we can't just
accept even if there are these double
standards uh we can't get to a point
where we simply accept it
Leanne Christie says Matt I think the
police department are being kept from
releasing the manifesto by politicians
yeah there's that there's probably
political pressure but I also think the
FBI you know the FBI has gotten involved
and they haven't said that they are
going to be investigating it as a hate
crime but they have said that they're
taking an advisory role or an assistance
role and uh I'm willing to bet that this
is what much of their advice consists of
finally John Adams says a physical
object cannot harm people only another
human being can harm another individual
all right that's the old uh you know
people kill guns they'll kill people
people kill people which is sort of I
mean people can use guns to kill people
right and and here's the way I look at
it and this is not a great analogy for a
few reasons but it helps to illustrate
at least one part of the point so
imagine that you're a parent you know
and you uh you come into the room one
day and you see like your 10 year old
son with a lighter trying to light the
cat on fire
now
which is the the more important question
so the kind of seeing that in fact the
parents of a lot of these Mass Shooters
have probably seen in the past which is
like an indication that your child
there's something deeply wrong with your
child
um and then too often these these uh
glaring warning signs are ignored
but you see something like that
what's the more important question
how did he get the lighter
or why in the hell is he doing this what
is going on inside him that is making
him do this
you could take the lighter away and you
should you know but you're still left
with a child who tries to light animals
on fire which means that there's a very
deep problem here and addressing it
simply by trying to control his access
to potentially harmful objects is a bad
strategy because you can't control his
access to harm harmful objects forever
and there are so many objects that can
be potentially harmful which is like
almost any object
um so you've got to get deeper than that
to figure out why would he you know most
kids uh even if they were to be able to
get their hands on a lighter wouldn't do
that okay most kids if they if they
there's there's there's something
specific here going on that needs to be
investigated
now I said this is bad analogy because
for one the government is not apparent
and two a child has no right to a
lighter in the first place and shouldn't
have one anyway as opposed to American
adults who don't have criminal records
who do have a right to own guns so it
doesn't work from those angles my point
is just to illustrate how we skip over
these deeper questions
um and you know and and that's why I
said to start with when it comes to in
response to this shooting and all the
other ones
the question is is why would why did
this person do this like all these
people there's a left warn us about all
the time
millions of people in this country own
guns that's true
okay but that only undermines their
point because you got millions of gun
owners millions of guns in circulation
and almost none of them are doing that
or whatever do that
okay I have guns it would there's zero
percent chance that I would ever go on a
killing spree
so why did this person do that
for most people having them owning a gun
A gun in their hands is not a danger to
anyone
in fact it could be helpful to other
people
it mitigates Danger
but for this small collection of evil
scumbags it they become a danger why is
that
and those are the questions we need to
be
focusing on
we know the left tends to reject
Concepts such as common sense science
tradition God ignoring the fundamentals
of Western Civilization may be tempting
for those who lack exposure to them but
It ultimately results in ignorance there
are absolutes you know in the world
including truth and Beauty Keith Gettys
the songwriter responsible for one of
the most glorious Modern Day hymns and
he discusses this idea in Jordan
Peterson's logos and literacy check it
out
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripture memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible Bible
printed on the Press of Johan goodberg
science and religion are opposing forces
in the world but historically that has
not been the case now the book is
available to everyone from Shakespeare
to modern education and medicine and
science to to civilization itself it is
the most influential book in all history
and hopefully people can walk away with
at least a sense of that
here's where I would normally tell you
that logos and literacy is only for
daily wire Plus members but we're making
it available for free for everyone at
dailywireplus.com it's only for a
limited time though so you got to watch
logos and literacy today at
dailywireplus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
thank you
our daily cancellation today begins with
a report in the New York Post about a
major and important controversy quote an
angry traveler has shared their
frustrations over a woman who had the
audacity quote unquote to request a seat
swap so she could sit next to her kid in
a resurface Reddit post now going viral
the flummoxed flyer said that it was
quote not my problem they didn't book
together when asked to switch seats the
unidentified traveler was on a
trans-pacific flight from Japan sitting
in a window seat while the toddler was
in the middle seat the tot's mom was in
the road directly behind them also
seated in the middle she asked me
quoting now and just made a switch with
her so she could have my window seat
next to her daughter and I'd have to
take her middle seat a row back
the user wrote hell to the F no the
peeve pasture continued in the post
worse as we were surrounded by others
from her tour group that she could have
asked for three-way trade instead or the
tour operator the audacity to just ask
me and expect an inferior trade on my
side
now many of the comments on Reddit and
on social media as this critically
important story has been shared far and
wide have come down against the man in
the window seat or the I don't know if
it's man the person in the window seat
claiming that it was his responsibility
to Forfeit the seat that he likely paid
extra money for and accept a much less
comfortable arrangement for a flight
across the Pacific Ocean all because
some stranger he doesn't know failed to
plan ahead
so as always
the internet Jury has ruled incorrectly
on this case
There are rules for seat trading on
airlines rules that this woman defied in
fact there are many rules governing
airline travel rules that that many
people constantly flout
these are not rules made or enforced by
the airlines themselves they have their
own rules but these are rules that exist
at a deeper level rules that are written
on the human heart I'm not speaking
about the laws of man but rather natural
laws laws that we should all understand
innately as human beings with rational
Souls
and if you don't understand these laws
then I will explain them to you right
now okay we have in the past touched on
many different aspects of air travel but
it's become apparent to me that that I
need to provide one resource with all of
the rules laid out in a clear and
accessible format and that's what we're
going to do today so this is the
definitive list of of rules of laws for
air travel we'll deal with the question
of uh seat swapping when we get there
but the rules begin well before you step
foot on the plane now in the interest of
time I'll only be able to cover the
rules that govern the time when you wake
up in the morning on the day of your
flight to the moment when you sit in
your seat on the plane
so this is this is the beginning of the
definitive list but it will not be the
entire list okay so let's proceed rule
number one
you dress like a civilized well-groomed
adult
if you're not that kind of adult then
you need to pretend that you are nobody
stumbles accidentally onto a plane you
have to book tickets you have to pack
you have to engage in some kind of
planning ahead of time so there's no
excuse to not be completely dressed and
showered and presentable when you get on
the plane now
if I knocked on your door in the middle
of the night well you probably call the
cops but let's say that you answered the
door you you'd be in your pajamas maybe
wearing slippers hair messy matted teeth
not brushed blurry eyed you know
unshowered confused and I could not
complain about having to look at you in
that disheveled and disgusting State
because I knocked on your door in the
middle of the night but when I see you
at the airport or on a plane I did not
knock on your door in the middle of the
night we are meeting out in public in a
place we both paid money to be and
planned ahead of time to be so I should
not have to be exposed to your middle of
the night look I should not have to see
you in your pajamas wearing slippers and
a bathrobe this this is this is an
airport it's not your bedroom
so put on some clothes you sloppy freak
that's rule number one rule number two
on that note there will be no sleeping
in the terminal okay I was at the
airport a couple of weeks ago sitting at
the gate and by far not the first time
this has happened there's a man five
feet from me laid out on the ground
curled up in the fetal position this has
grown man jacket pulled over him like a
blanket fast asleep now once again this
is an airport it's not your bedroom it's
also not a refugee camp so forget about
the fact that by sleeping on the ground
at the airport you are displaying an
extremely unreasonable amount of faith
in the airport's janitorial staff
the truth is that that patch of floor
you're lying on was probably last clean
during like the first Bush
Administration not to mention you're
displaying enough in even more
unreasonable amount of faith in other
people
do you actually trust other humans
enough to become voluntarily unconscious
amid a huge crowd of them
well you shouldn't but that's not even
the point the point is that I don't want
to have to look at you like that it's
undignified it's embarrassing
okay you can take a nap when you get to
the hotel the airport is a place for
being awake and tired and miserable like
the rest of us
rule number three
so you got into the airport you're awake
like everybody else like a like a
civilized adult now we're boarding the
plane when boarding the plane remember
that you're on you are on stoplight time
okay what do I mean by that well when
you're sitting at a stop light and the
light turns green and then a second
passes and you still haven't moved the
cars behind you will start blaring their
horns and screaming curses at you and
throwing eggs and tomatoes at your
windshield and they will be morally
justified in doing so that's because at
a stoplight each second counts as 10
minutes if you wait two seconds to move
that you've actually been sitting there
for 20 minutes three seconds it's been a
half hour and now it's both morally and
from what I understand legally
acceptable for the cars behind you to
Ram into you and force you through the
intersection
now when boarding a plane time works
exactly the same way it's not normal
time you have to understand that you
have less than one second therefore to
Stow your bags and get in your seat okay
you're getting on the plane keep it
moving Stow the baggage so you have less
than a second to do it if you bring a
bag on board that doesn't fit in the
overhead storage and now we have to wait
not only seconds but even minutes
minutes while the situation is resolved
you have in effect delayed us by years
we are years behind schedule because of
you and we hate you for it
one of the note about boarding a plane
if you're running late for your flight
and and will now be boarding after
everybody else has already taken their
seats
you're not going to like this but this
is the rule the rule dictates that you
don't board at all your trip is canceled
you're not flying
because first of all you've held us all
up and now you have to pay the price for
it but also second the other people in
your row now assume that you aren't
coming and they have experienced the
joyful Elation at the thought that
they'll have extra space on their flight
it is deeply painful to believe that the
person next to you isn't showing up only
to see them appear out of nowhere five
seconds before the doors shut sweaty
exhausted like out of breath happy that
they made the flight
totally unconcerned by by the trauma
that's been being inflicted on you now
that you realize that this sweaty person
is me sitting next to you
so if you're running that late you don't
get to board Rule Number Four
to deal with the issue we would began
with if you have a problem with your
seat you need to trade with somebody
else on the flight you may only propose
a lateral trade window seat for a window
seat aisle for now because I'm generous
I'll even allow you to propose a window
for Aisle or aisle for window trade but
what you cannot ever do under any
circumstance is try to trade your middle
seat for someone else's end seat too big
a favor to ask if someone you don't know
it's like going up to some stranger in a
parking garage and asking them to take
your 2011 Toyota Corolla with a broken
air conditioning and 150 000 miles on it
in exchange for their luxury sedan
well I guess no seat on a modern Airline
is tantamount to a luxury sedan so it's
more like asking to exchange your beat
up disgusting Toyota Corolla for a
slightly less beat up and disgusting
Toyota Corolla either way it's it's a
laughable proposition and it's
inappropriate to even request
rule number five finally for now
once you're sitting in your seat here
are all the things you may not do you
may not lean back your chair seats are
equipped with this function but not
because you're supposed to actually use
it the recline option on the seat is
just there as a test to see who is a
sociopath if you hit the button you fail
the test
you may not eat any food that gives off
a strong smell or makes any kind of
sound so this rule basically rules out
all food except for white plain white
bread is all you're allowed to eat on
the plane if you're sitting next to me
anyway
you may not speak to the person next to
you unless you're spoken to but they
also are following the same rule which
means that nobody's speaking at all if
you're in the middle seat as I've
explained in the past
you have no Privileges and no human
rights you are worse than a second class
citizen you don't exist
this means that you don't have
permission to use either of your
armrests your superiors on the end get
both of their armrests you get nothing
you're also not allowed to inconvenience
the aisle seat by getting up to use the
bathroom you must sit there legs
together arms folded head bound bound
down in silence for the duration of the
flight
now if you're sitting in the window seat
you need to use the bathroom you may
impose this inconvenience on the aisle
seat but only once per six hours of the
flight so if your flight is less than
six hours you're not permitted access to
the bathroom at all
now this as I said only a partial list
of rules enough to get you on the plane
and seated as for how to conduct
yourself during the flight and get off
the flight uh well we'll have to cover
those rules at a different time what I
would recommend is that nobody take any
flights at all until I've had a chance
to cover the entire list of rules for
now though anyone who has ever violated
rules one through five
is of course banned from flying from
here on out and also obviously today
canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to members block become a
member today by using Code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
hopes you over the members block if not
we'll talk to you tomorrow got
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign